esto es Marte y estas imágenes
aceleradas fueron las primeras
transmitidas desde el planeta en vivo
fueron filmadas desde la nave Marx
Express de la agencia espacial europea
como el planeta rojo está actualmente a
unos 300 millones de kilómetros de la
tierra a las imágenes de estomo un
tiempo en llegar 18 minutos la cámara de
seguimiento visual de 20 años de
antigüedad que lleva a bordo solo puede
captar imágenes cada 50 segundos aún así
es una Primicia histórica una forma de
marcar el 20 aniversario de Marx Express
2 de junio de 2003 el lanzamiento fue un
gran Éxito para la ae aunque no todas
sus misiones han tenido éxito Marx
Express ha permitido a la agencia hacer
descubrimientos como confirmar con sus
sensores y el radar marsis que hay lagos
subterráneos en el planeta rojo también
ha detectado una nube sobre un volcán
Marciano la nave se utiliza para recoger
imágenes de los rovers en el suelo
Marciano y transmitirlas a la Tierra
esta vez la transmisión fue casi en
directo de una cámara que terminó su
misión original hace más de una década